hold on there partners before we get
this show started we got a real special
announcement from down here in aunt
doody's basement
uncle hank and kippy a couple of city
slickers are going to be heading out
down south
we're going to be at raleigh good nights
in north carolina april 20th it's coming
up
the next night we're going to be in
zany's nashville so get some ticks
yeah guys it's going to be a good time
we're going to be doing some live
stand-up t-bones coming with us
and then we're going to be doing uh some
live ayg with you guys you guys are
gonna
give us questions we're gonna be asking
you questions uh so grab some friends
come on out it's gonna be fun we're
gonna be [ __ ] on your stupid uncle
ted
or whoever comes your buddies your buddy
steve who's an [ __ ] it's gonna be a
good time correct don't be showing up
with sneaks and no socks on
we're gonna rip on you we're gonna we're
gonna be having some beers we're gonna
be taking some pics we're gonna be
hanging out
we'll see you there now let's get the
show started welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey
hey hey hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast
this is ru garbage oh yeah a little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out if they grow up to be
classy
or they're just a big old piece of trash
it's ain't your mama's podcast that's
right
i'm your host stage foley coming at you
on a glorious day
we're down here in aunt toddy's basement
little quiet upstairs
why what's going on teddy went to the
phillies game last night when she told
me she was going to the stadium last
night
sure okay uh turns out no game
they were away stealing concessions
caught
god broad street apparently got her in
the jet draw a lot too busted cold yeah
yikes
so she's going to be uh staying with
some friends for the next couple of days
oh yeah we got to get her out that's
pape that's patreon.com
you garbage everybody yeah get a suit
for the arraignment yeah
my co-host is coming at you for me or
teddy
today would wear a suit to the
arraignment paula pounce don't go with
it
yeah cody would dress like a dude for
sure while she
puts a mustache on i don't know what
you're talking about said you were
looking for a broad oh
gang my co-host is coming at you from
across the table so you know
what that means this is a family episode
every once in a while it's good to
circle the wagons it's good to
let the company stay home and us as a
family just reconnect
and have a nice time because we need it
because we need it
need to feel the love little group
therapy action going on
at ru garbage kevin james ryan hey gang
happy to be here thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube and as
the three of us know
those numbers are true to roof true
true to [ __ ] roof also this just in
patreon.com are you garbage is [ __ ]
true to [ __ ] rooftop okay
we got two five two grills going over
here
how do you like them thank you pick your
poison boys are [ __ ] cooking we're
doing some numbers things are going well
we appreciate all supports yes
if you're not familiar uh patreon.com
you get bonus episodes
that aren't released to the public
people are still hitting me up they
don't get that
these we just they live and die on
patreon that's it they don't go out on
itunes you're not getting them early
that's the they're only on patreon yeah
so exclusive content
get bonus apps of ayg on patreon you get
hard episodes of hard feelings which is
just mean the big man chopping it up
shooting the [ __ ] making fun of each
other a little hr
right it's a little behind the curtain
it's a good time it's a good time that's
the runaway hit too
everybody loves we have more people at
that level than the five dollar like a
julia roberts movie
it is baby i love it uh and then also
for our top tier members we play
ru garbage once a month with you guys
via live stream sometimes twice a month
it's a good time get involved peeps
fantastic uh
and also raleigh good night's april 20th
april 21st zany's nashville that's the
first leg of the tour
just added a bunch more dates we're
gonna be moving and shaking all summer a
little bit
i know we got some we got some [ __ ]
things cooking but nashville and raleigh
we need a little help so grab a couple
of trash bag friends come on out we're
gonna be playing ayg with you guys
we're gonna be doing some stand up it'll
be a good [ __ ] time we're gonna have
some pops
kippy's having a pop i'll be working at
the kinks a little bit too so it'll be
good
sure you guys are getting some tune-up
games too by the way
real behind the scenes it'll be a good
time t-bone's coming too
t-bone and
it's so funny that you said that because
i was about to get to him how about a
nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man t-bone
mcmuffin
toby mcmullen what up what up dog yeah i
really hitched my horse to a
three-wheeled wagon here
[ __ ] hobbling all over this [ __ ]
country whatever it's gonna be a hot one
baby
it's gonna be fantastic manifest destiny
we're not all making it to california
i'll tell you that
nope louisiana purchase is gonna go
south
we need a handicapped parking and a
rascal quick what happened to foley he
died of dysentery in alabama
did you guys do dates there now i just
went down for a sandwich we told him how
to drink the bond water he wasn't
listening i heard the producers were
good what do you want from me
um gang this is a family episode we're
going to be reading your questions we're
going to be shooting the [ __ ] a little
bit
uh the one thing i wanted to get to and
it's
first of all i want to say the patreon
questions
everybody on the facebook group even the
stereo app
sometimes the questions [ __ ] blow you
away sometimes i mean we also on this
one
we got some [ __ ] yeah heavy hit
what's up
they're funny it's also because i think
that they should be doing the podcast
they should be watching
i know the listeners are they've heard
so many questions and then they
they understand that they'll they'll ask
it how will
ask it like they'll be it'll be in the
phrase like have you or any of your
parents ever done this
the how many how many windows did you
have in your room on twitter
on twitter that's a [ __ ] i wish i had
that guy's name right yeah how many ha
how many uh windows in your bedroom did
you have growing up
i had one and then i had at one point i
lived in a room with no windows
wait i said like under your parents roof
it was i had moved out to go to school
uh but i would come back in high school
they put you in the pantry what kind of
room has no windows
toby get in the mud room dude it was
like sleeping in a
[ __ ] casino you didn't wake up
pumping oxygen in there changing 500. no
clocks
[Laughter]
wait a minute man so you would went to
college your parents had moved
my parents moved into a condo one of
high school damn yeah and then i would
come back to visit
empty nesters yeah yeah and uh oh that's
right they shipped you off to [ __ ]
boarding school that is correct
and you got a condo yes damn not really
planning for t-bone's return
no if that's saying something without
saying something yeah
just locking me in a dark room with a
combo vhs dvd player saying reach the
cop to himself
dude that's [ __ ] weird man i'd be so
pissed at my parents
first of all one window i'm [ __ ]
losing it no windows i'm freaking the
[ __ ]
out i think i had two i had two yeah you
had two yeah like a gentleman i had two
like a gentleman's ceilings were really
close together though
what do you mean they're not eyes
yours could have been one big one but
okay i'm just saying
i will say they moved again one window
and your boy was puffing jeebies out to
out that [ __ ]
what gravity bungs toby i wonder why
they didn't want you living with them
yeah
right i wonder why they put me to
windowless rooms yeah i would have
shipped you off to boarding school for
sure too who's doing gravity bongs in
their room by themselves
[ __ ] that's a party that's a social
event yeah that's like hey
we've small smoked weed ten thousand
times let's make it a little interesting
he's got that in a full nitrous tank
two for five it's just you toby
i don't mind if i do he's passing it
like this
jesus dude but anyway that's the [ __ ]
level of
of [ __ ] that we get which is [ __ ]
fantastic which makes these so much fun
i love them and we get jealous sometimes
of how good they are
yeah because we're supposed to be you
know we're supposed to be the
connoisseur
sure and they come in with something
well truth be told every once in a while
i'll get a suggestion or something like
that that i hadn't thought of oh yeah
we're already working on that
really oh yeah man this guy's [ __ ]
he's he'll be shaking your hand and
taking your watch at the same time this
guy
i i get upset because obviously we have
like a huge running like i have like a
list of like
anyone that's anyone i've ever asked is
in my phone right and i'll add to that
so i'm like i'll go back and pull them
or whatever and uh
sometimes i have um i'm keeping them for
a guest i have in mind
sure and then someone will ask it or
tweet it it'll come up and i want to be
like dude i already had that but it
sounds like
it sounds like what you doing yeah oh
well i already got that one in the
hopper
i've been working on dylan's list for
like six months yeah i'm working all day
i'm working on bears too i started
working on birds about nine months ago
when you were in star wars yeah
but then for all the good ones you get
every now and again we'll get like have
you ever stolen diabetes needles for
heroin
yeah it's a lot some of you guys are
[ __ ] trees yeah what was the one like
you ever [ __ ] your buddy's sister or
something like yeah it was like yeah but
it was like super specific it was like
did you ever [ __ ] your buddy sister
trina
and then bobby comes home and you're
like buddy i
you gotta go see somebody yeah do [ __ ]
um
but we came across one uh on the old
stereo app a couple weeks ago
and it just it just it's a very simple
question
but there's so much to it there's a lot
to unpack yeah we wanted to break it
down a little bit
because it because it is it is kind of
an interesting thing sure
um do you remember the name questions
from jeremy jeremy
our boy jeremy uh on stereo and the
question is
is it garbage to own one
jet ski one jet ski
yeah i mean oh dude there's a lot
in that because it's like you don't have
money for two
right i would assume so which probably
if you don't have money for two jet skis
you probably don't have money for one
jet ski
no you should as i'm saying you
shouldn't be putting your money in the
jet ski basket
if there's one jet ski in the family it
does not have insurance
yeah yeah it doesn't have any changes
it's probably not registered either
you don't have a license if it's a one
jet ski family i would be led to believe
that the family are not jet ski people
and somebody came across a little bit of
cash
all right probably from a blue collar
job scratch or maybe
something big big big season with uh
cleaning up leaves or something like
that it was a real windy year i don't
know
all right and it doesn't work like that
you got it it's got to be there's got to
be multiple choices
it's a group activity right like
you'd ride with something nobody ever
will you or like yeah like you and your
buddies go out
jet skiing i guess i don't we had them
growing up
how many did you have at least two
see yeah i mean some were like real we
had two like really old
like you didn't have actual like the
skis the one that stands things are
[ __ ]
trash dude those things are for like you
you're a certain death
you're right those are the orgies dude
nobody regular people ain't right that
those are jet skis wave runners the
first time i yeah the first time i went
i went
on a on a wave runner i was like we were
like 15 down
down at that it was just a regular
[ __ ] boat you were right you were
just so big you were riding like a jet
ski it was there was a center console
it was down the jersey shore we were
running it from this place down there i
think you were in the bahamas
[Laughter]
we were in san tropez but uh we ended up
getting arrested we got pulled over by
the [ __ ] coast guard out there
they get you because they didn't have
any insurance on any of the bikes there
was no [ __ ] uh
numbers like it wasn't like nj the
register no there was no
fire extinguishers in in the things
where there was supposed to be all this
[ __ ]
we got hauled down to [ __ ] uh cape
may county courthouse the whole [ __ ]
lot had to go down how old for you
i was like 15. jesus brought us all in
like months later we had to come down
like in the fall
down the shore in the fall what am i an
animal yeah that's a bad luck
wait so i'm a little confused on the
question is it is it you only own one
jet ski
yes okay but so so that that's the only
watercraft you own because a lot of
people have a boat and a jet ski
sure this guy doesn't yeah i think i
think the idea
is just a jet ski yeah like just a wave
runner
well cause it's also like i guess i
don't know they're
they're always in pairs like it's a
think about it okay say you're on the
lake the family's over
you got to take turns on the [ __ ] jet
ski and part of it
you're riding with some but like you're
like oh yeah you're like zipping around
zipping around also too you know
whenever this is how you know it's a
group activity because no one's ever
gone by themselves and rented one
right no like you can rent them in new
york which i want to [ __ ] do
i would not do that we can drive around
the whole island of manhattan i'm not
going
to go down the hudson up the [ __ ]
i tried to convince schultz to renee jet
ski and race alex media and his tesla
they both start in brooklyn and they
have to get to the tip of manhattan yeah
they weren't having it
i would do it johnny mountain dew over
here yeah right
hey red bull take it easy listen can
anybody get a hang glider
i need a helicopter that can do
backflips i need a hang glider and a
cheetah by tomorrow
extreme mcmullen
[Laughter]
toby extreme but i like me racing an
elephant
i went kayaking in the it was it was
when me and my lady first started dating
she came here for my birthday
and she talked to you remember didn't
she organize something with you
or maybe it might have been uh macaroni
i forgot i'm gonna chatted her up a
little bit
taking a shot of hey while you're in
town why don't you come over i'm doing a
set down there at the village lantern
i think the bald guy's going after me
show you what you're missing out on but
she got me she like
she got me a [ __ ] she surprised me
with uh
kayaking in the in the hudson that's not
a surprise for my birthday
and like she told me and i'm like but
this is we're still so new like this is
the first or second the second time she
came back i think
she did that last week and it was like
get the [ __ ] dude
you're out there and the [ __ ] first
of all that's what i'm saying in order
to not you have to you're
you have to paddle to stay in place just
to even stay in place because the
currents are strong
and then the [ __ ] fairies are zipping
around and dude they're like
it's it's a [ __ ] scene dude we took a
ferry a couple weeks ago those things
are hauling
[ __ ] yes shout out if you they don't
do it anymore because
dude take a ferry it's like it's the
same as a subway ride it's like 250 or
275 or something like that
you can hop on all day and they serve
beers on the boat
so you can just hang out your [ __ ]
couple of countries couple of brooklyn
ipas and stuff it's a good time yeah it
gives you perspective of the city yeah
you just zipper you zip around the whole
city for two bucks
jet ski could give you perspective too
if you're with somebody yeah that's what
i'm saying no one's
giving you a [ __ ] dirt kill there's a
point no one's just renting a jet no one
person
is going to rent a jet ski by themselves
and just history just like from from
what anybody i've known
that like i said there wasn't like a
community of jet ski people in the
family
it was just oh ronnie ronnie went out
and bought a jet ski
so now when we go to the shore ronnie's
gonna have this jet ski
ronnie's not gonna have a slip he's
gonna have to back the [ __ ] car in
you know what i mean yeah usually if you
have one jet ski and it's on a trailer
it is not hooked up to a uh a pickup
truck
it's hooked up to a regular car yeah
like a hatchback and that's [ __ ]
garbage yeah yeah yeah
you're backing that thing down the down
the thing to drop it in the water
no yeah it's [ __ ] horrible uh that's
my that's that that's how we feel that
one jet ski
even though it's an expensive purchase
it's a purely leisure
uh vehicle i mean it doesn't serve any
purpose
and that's another thing too about the
jet ski itself i was trying to think of
anything
because like a boat you can go fishing
okay kayaks exercise
usually it's something on the water even
though it is leisure it does serve
somewhat of a purpose or the vehicle
could if need be
you're not doing anything on a wave
runner sure except maybe saving a surfer
out of it it's just fun yeah when you're
surfing the big kahunas in hawaii
or something you know when they drive
them in and drop them off sure those
guys are nuts by the way
what the surfers are all of them no way
never when i go out there big man
doesn't like the ocean would you put
singular jet ski in the same category as
camaro which is
the shittiest thing you can spend 30
thousand dollars on yeah they're both
going to break down pretty quickly
similar and you can't like it's not a
group back to camaro you get what
another guy in that's it
or bro i'm just saying you get one
this guy's cruising around with his
buddies trying to score some tail over
here
i'm
i mean you can't be dropping your kids
off to school in a [ __ ] camaro let's
just say ask your sister
my dad had a mustang when he was young
yeah no you got to be a step dad for
them to give you the papers the camaro
yeah my stepdad never had one he had
like big jacked up trucks though
yeah like jacked up he went the other
way yeah he's a real hillbilly right
your toy's over whenever you're thinking
about it yeah
yeah yeah it was like and then dude he
had this one white suburban when my mom
first met him
this thing was the size of both sides of
toddy's basement
dude this thing was huge and he had
about this is a rough estimate
37 antennas on it
[Laughter]
cb cb he had satellite right he had like
a
he had a [ __ ] dish network thing on
there it was a [ __ ] not npr i can
tell you that no not npr
yeah yeah yeah uh just like antennas
dude for everything
i didn't like those older suburban still
was it the one that like it's almost
they're almost like uh like bench seats
like before they like made them nice
remember like the ones
oh you know i'm saying it's old like
this is like probably like an 87. or
something those things were frightening
big metal
body like not yeah big chrome fenders on
this thing i remember pulling the doors
on one of those things like what was the
[ __ ] bank vault
it's like a brinks truck dude trying to
get in the back
get my goldfish on what the [ __ ] dude
yeah i hated that because a couple of my
older cousins they also had like
one head of monte carlo and i remember
trying to [ __ ] get into that thing
it'd take like three kids to [ __ ]
pull the door up now
climb in the back seat and get caught
those were heavy um all right let's get
the way they used to make cars is so
trash looking back on it
[ __ ] insane how i don't know how you
fix a car
that's all like steel like those old
what are they just bang out the [ __ ]
ring yeah yeah yeah jesus christ i mean
i don't even know how they do it what
are they doing this exact way
i mean it's all in the same breath if
that's not the most holy thing
how do you do that through the exact
process i'm about to explain
okay now me i can work on a carbon fiber
body but uh
all steel i don't know what i'm doing ah
man
very good folks are you tired of years
of getting ripped off by
big wireless providers if we've learned
anything
it's there's always a catch oh yeah
there's always a little something
underneath they get you coming and going
sure something for new customers old
customers it doesn't add up it's all
shifty
so when we first heard of mint mobile
here at the ru garbage podcast
we knew that we had to get involved
and pass the savings on the u and they
have plans starting at 15
bucks a month and you're thinking of
course watch the catch
but after speaking with them and using
their service it all made sense
there isn't one there's no catch mint
mobile secret sauce
is that they're the first company to
sell wireless service online
only by cutting out retail stores there
is no crazy overhead cost
that those savings can get passed down
to you as the consumer
there's no mystery fees there's no this
no that mint just passes
savings on direct to you yeah guys
it sounds it sounds too good to be true
and it's really not
uh we i've actually my wife has been
using it uh when she moved to the u.s
that's what we got her uh because she
was here temporarily we're like right
instead of enrolling
with one of the big companies and paying
all these fees to cancel at some point
we got her that and then she's just kept
it because it's been so easy so
convenient
you can reload it really is 15 bucks a
month
for all it's it's really great they sent
us one she's using it it's
it's a no-brainer i recommend it it's
easy easy to use easy to do all plans
come with unlimited talc and text
high speed data delivered on nation's
largest 5g network
not bad use your own phone with mint and
you can keep your same number along with
all your existing contacts it's easy
peasy guys and if you're not 100
satisfied mint mobile
has you covered with their seven-day
money-back guarantee so you can try it
if you realize it's not for you
no harm no foul you go right back switch
to mint mobile i'm switching that's it
dude dude she my wife's been using it
for
two years goes on the internet the whole
nine yards whatever she wants to do
whole nine yards it's not enough to
minute dude it's fantastic
when they came on i was like oh this is
great um switch to mint mobile and get
premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month and get
shipped right to your door free go to
mintmobile.com
garbage that's mint mobile.com garbage
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks with
mint gang today's podcast is brought to
you by our good friends
at better help oh yeah which we could
not be more excited about
you know kippy and i are very big on
mental health we want everybody feeling
good
and if you're not feeling good and you
got to do something about it better help
can help yeah they're a fantastic
organization betterhelp will
assess your needs and match you with our
own licensed professional therapist
so it's not a situation you get to go
talk to somebody you get to talk to
somebody
online privately you know you don't have
to go and sit in a waiting or whatever
you can start communicating with
somebody in under 48 hours it's not a
crisis hotline
it's not a self-help hotline what it is
it's a professional
counseling done securely online in the
privacy of your own home
and there in many areas services
available for clients worldwide
you can log into your account anytime
and send a message to your counselor
yeah guys you'll get timely thought out
responses and you can schedule weekly or
just regular phone calls sessions you
don't ever have to sit in that waiting
room and feel weird people hearing you
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches
so they can make it easy and free to
change counselors if you want to
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available if you need it mental health
is very important so take action guys
visit their website and read their
testimonials that are posted there daily
uh if you visit betterhelp.com garbage
that's betterhelp.com
garbage help help and join the 1 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health
and you can get help from an experienced
professional
it's available in all 50 states uh with
better help
and uh you can use our special offer
are you garbage listeners get ten
percent off your first month at better
get that betterhelphelp.com
garbage gang let's face it going to the
post office
probably probably not how you want to
spend your time
nope could be a weirdo you like hanging
out in there i don't know but for most
of us
we like to keep it moving as they say
that's why we're recommending and
mailing and shipping online
at stamps.com you know them you love
them
it's not like they're a new startup nah
everybody knows stamps.com the ogs guys
are rock solid yeah stamps.com
allows you to mail and ship anytime
anywhere right from your computer you
can send letters you can ship packages
and you could pay a lot less with
discounted rates
from usps and ups and more
stamps.com has saved businesses
thousands of hours and tons of money
with stamps.com you get the service of
the post office and ups
all in one place plus you get big big
big discounts on mailing and shipping
rates yeah guys i know we have a lot of
uh small business owners out there it's
a no-brainer we use it uh they send us a
package they give you a free they give
you uh some free shipping they give you
the scale we use it to send out all the
calls
you bought cards you you used it there
you go boom it's easy peasy we did it
all from hoodies you set it up it prints
it out super easy
throw the label on there out the door
you can set up a pickup
it's simple if you have a computer and a
wi-fi and an internet connection if
you're in your car your apartment your
office your garage and today's basement
wherever you are you can do it
with stamps.com you get 40 off post
offices up off
post office rates and 62 percent off ups
shipping rates that is a no
brainer baby stamps.com saves time
and money it's no wonder there's a
million small businesses who already use
it so stop wasting time by going to the
post office
and go to stamps.com instead there's no
risk and with our promo code garbage
that's g-a-r-b-a-g-e you'll get a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments
or contracts required stick and move
baby give it a beat it give it a shot if
you don't like it
you don't have to use it it's easy but
you're gonna yeah just go to stamps.com
click the microphone at the top of the
home page and type in
our promo code garbage do it stamps.com
never go to the post office again
now back to the show [ __ ]
uh we got some i think we got some hot
[ __ ] questions a lot of first timers
too
shout out uh guys someone obviously when
you know when you join the patreon
we'll we'll answer your question what
how does he use the word first timers
well i have to make a note if you
haven't had this kid's google search
if you haven't had a question asked let
me know like you know indicate it so we
can get to
everybody because you know um
all right let's see here uh this one's
for mark first time long time have you
ever had
any trash have you ever had any family
members that were bookies
[Laughter]
i've dabbled in the book making
profession a little bit a little
like high school we would you know we
were gambling a lot but nobody ever
in my proper fam couple couple of
people close to the family for sure yeah
taking bets
money and paper bags type thing but yeah
yeah no never had that next question
i played the fifth uh what was his name
again
what was his name mark hey mark keep
your [ __ ] mouth shut all right
i'm wearing a wire you [ __ ] snitch
uh when you're when you're young like i
remember in
college i i didn't have the two things i
didn't have the balls to do in college
was sell
weed you know what i mean to [ __ ]
make make scratch
or or to be a bookie because there was a
couple of my boys
that uh that like ran the book for the
school
and they weren't particularly tough you
know what i mean they were just smart
savvy guy
takes a specific kind of guy of course
especially in college
he's usually a pretty cool kid yeah i
didn't have that
no but they did that it was cool then
but as you get older
it's like and you're doing serious
things sure
yeah yeah yeah i may or may not have
some acquaintances that are uh
involved i may or may not as well
all right next one dude this is a
[ __ ] home run this came in
uh this is from oliver just joined y'all
are killing it with the content thank
you ali
thank you ollie we appreciate it uh how
this is
even the way he asks is great how do you
how do you
how do you secure a cold cut sandwich in
your lunch
is it in tin foil or a plastic bag
because growing up we work here yes
the way he's secure like it's a [ __ ]
jewel or something
because we were a plastic bag fan i
remember if you got tinfoil it was like
well let me ask you this were you the
plastic bag family that you had to fold
over
or were you a zip lock kid i i still
look at zip locks like if they're
expensive
like uh if i have them see the ones that
have the zipper on top
because foley was loose sandwich in pot
i put one piece of bread in one pocket
salami in my back pocket
i put it together lettuce up your ass
put it together like a hitman on the
roof
paulie's walking out with a big loaf of
bread
in a guitar case
paulie what are you doing i'm going to
the roof to have my lunch
there was a second eater
[Laughter]
yeah we got an active fat kid over there
what's like in high school
there's an active eater in the cafeteria
oh we were the full though i i dude i'm
not even joking
my wife bought the ziploc buys the
ziploc bags and like
i won't use them because they're
expensive in my like they're nice
i in my head i'm like well uh these are
an asset i don't want to get and then in
my head
i'm like well they're [ __ ] 2.99 and
we're making a little bit of cake the
foley's garbage level
uh we we when we started so
let's say we had those and we had the
the wrap ones
sure shitty ones we were the wrap all
day the shitty ones would be used for
sandwiches
those zip locks were used for like other
things than
food like there would be like keys or
change
vicodin or for a while i remember my mom
was putting like her id and all she was
like using one as a wallet
i don't know why she's garbage
what do you mean you don't know why
because they're clean and nice cause
you're dirty dirty on the beach they're
nice or like a water park yeah you know
what was like i
did i remember my buddy busted out one
time one of the half jaw
the hat the little guys oh these were
past your time i don't know where you
get there dude the little the half of a
ziploc bag a couple of pretzel rods fit
nice dude what a
goldfish and i remember being like dude
what does your dad do for a living
does he work for ziploc i used to get
sent i used to get sent
with the [ __ ] flip over the roll over
with
[ __ ] hers pretzels it would all be
crumpled
falling out in the bag and [ __ ] i did i
remember at one point sitting there
going these
don't work tell them to get some bubble
wrap in here
you're crunching my [ __ ] security mom
these are for dime bags only i know it
didn't makes
i just remember now she now she does
well back then that was new technology
too it was a little more expensive i
could never figure out how to flip it
overnight my mom would always do it
perfect on the sandwich
well things now you know i think things
changed a lot
in the 90s to spend like four bucks on a
bag of zip
a box of ziplocks or like 199 on like
the flippers
that was a thousand of them that was way
did now it's like four bucks whatever
yeah but back then i feel it was just
like you were like
that's like that's just a waste of money
i don't know i've known from my niece
and nephew that
a lot of things have changed as far as
packing lunch i don't think anybody's
rolling in with a brown paper bag
anymore
they all have these little soft like
koozie they were they're dorks
they were they when they those came out
when we are and my mom like got me one
with like a soccer ball and i was like
yo tuts
hit the [ __ ] breaks it's pizza day
kid can't even play
[Laughter]
we were we were definitely tin foil for
all
really yeah we would only break out the
tin foil
uh on the beach or when we went skiing
we would pack our lunches to go skiing
and have it in the lodge because like 20
of us would go
mm-hmm and like all like kids and that i
would get a [ __ ] app
a [ __ ] amoroso roll with [ __ ]
skippy peanut butter on it
roll that up throw it in a [ __ ]
cooler with some ice
good nice screaming can of coke some
goldfish
yeah we're in a jelly kid nah i'm not a
jelly guy now
we'll use the tinfoil for the sandwich
and for the soda wrap up the soda
my body i remember that's [ __ ] trash
wrapping up but my buddy did that i
remember in
the [ __ ] element i'm like wrapping up
a soda keeps it a little bit colder
i kind of like it a little warm gives
you a nice bite to it
the trick she used to do that was the
[ __ ] best and i mentioned it before
is little debbie oatmeal pies that were
in the freezer
and for some reason by seventh period
when those things [ __ ] warmed up a
little bit
oh was they eating raw oatmeal cookies
though
that's what you need good time no jelly
is
insane yeah no jelly's weird i'm still
that way dude
still that way what about a nice jam on
a on a muffin
no dude they even really they give you
jelly in jail dude
you're eating like a janitor's kid how
about like a fake jam if you order like
a charcuterie board
yeah for sure okay throw that on a
cracker with some brie or something i'm
not a [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm cultured i
just don't
i'm a i like the texture of it i'm a i
don't need that [ __ ] jelly getting in
my way
straight peanut butter kids [ __ ]
stayed clear them on the playground
that's why we only became friends later
on in life
he's got a dry mouth and nothing to lose
no dude i would go through like
i would go through a half a gallon of
milk eating one sammy and i loved it
there'd be peanut butter all over the
cup [ __ ] going out
yeah on your grip hand yeah yeah it'd be
all over the rim
oh it's nasty taste it now i was trying
to this is this is garbage
uh d have you ever it only happens with
water
do you ever if you're eating something
with water if you're eating dinner and
you're drinking water
never happens and like the lips get on
there you know you're like
like a glass of water yeah and then like
as you go to take the sip it smells like
fish or something like that
it freaks me out i don't know what
you're talking about but with a cup are
you eating fish
no but for some reason it gets like a
fishy smell around the cup i don't know
what you're talking about
no that's yeah you're on your own with
that
use that for a patreon or something i'll
save that for are you weird
sometimes my glass smells this one's a
home run this is for
sometimes and i don't like to drink the
water
that's why i do like a little lemon in
it now because i feel like it kills
anything
any scent in there ah it's good yeah
yeah you think a lot of things that
don't make any sense
fair enough uh all right this one's from
steve isaacs this is a [ __ ] i mean
uh do you did you ever have a barbecue
girl in the front yard
which i mean come on yeah that's that's
embarrassing
yeah t-boned you ever cook in your in
your non
well i don't i don't know what i was
going to say i lost a flat tire that one
he's grilling in his room
yeah did you ever grow in the pantry no
never
well your parents probably weren't grill
people right
no not really i mean i'm getting a vibe
not a fun squad
no i wonder if i want to see mug shots
of your parents do you ever have family
parties and like your dad grilling and
stuff like that
no no my my mom does the cooking my dad
doesn't cook [ __ ] but but my parents are
fun they would have like
the entire neighborhood over and just
get bombed [ __ ] booze bags
yeah that's pretty cool i like that but
like but like martinis and like
gimlets and [ __ ] like that you know like
classy
alkies yeah but not really fun for the
kids
no i don't know that's why t-bone's such
a hoot yeah
i don't know i don't know too many
eight-year-olds that are in the dirty
martinis
that's why t-bone can't drink anymore
yeah exactly
yeah but instead of grilling we just
have like a bottle of vodka
[Laughter]
um all right let's see uh this one's
from sean mack
this is a two-parter shawnee yeah uh
have you ever been part of a class
action lawsuit and have you ever called
a lawyer from a commercial on tv
holy [ __ ] like celino and barnes or i'm
eighth rosenberg the injury lawyer i
might have called
i might have called j.g wentworth on a
whim or something like that
really yeah there's also that thing too
that reminds me of like you can put your
social security number
if you there's cash on the street you
know it yeah
you don't run the type operation where
you forget someone owes you money some
uncle you never met
yeah clash action lawsuit no
i i remember when i found out what they
were i still don't kind of understand
i've seen erin brockovich
yeah so a lot of time i remember uh it
was like
one came for like mastercard or
something where they were charging
international fees wrong
right and like everybody got together
and was suing them for like all this
money that they were overcharged or
something you were involved in this
then it came to my house because like my
mom and stepdad had a mastercard or
whatever like they just sent it out to
anybody like hey if you've traveled and
used your mastercard you could be
eligible
to win this life so this wasn't even you
it was your parents yeah i was a kid i
didn't know and i was like i was like
you don't want your be quick well that's
i started looking
i mean i know a scam when i see one you
know what i mean so i start
i'm like i was i don't know maybe 12 or
i don't know i was young and i'm like
what's i like read it and i'm like so
you just gotta say
that you did this and you can [ __ ]
you can get a couple of points over here
you know what i mean you go wet your
beak and my mom's like yeah but we don't
do that and i was like
that's like one of they have these weird
things you don't get correction lady
you don't do that cause kitty's about to
enroll in mastercard.com now i'll need
your license and a copy of your
signature and what was the last time you
were in canada by the way
no [ __ ] yeah but i've seen those bridges
i'm i always thought you were thinking
more like uh like bad zantek or
something like that
like like mesothelioma or something yeah
yeah
yeah no i've never done that no
if i did i wouldn't and plus you only
get like [ __ ] 10 bucks if like
the judgment's a hundred million the
lawyers get like
whatever 50 of that because they're
doing it all on the cuff knowingly
they're going to get a payday
so the lawyers get 50 and then the other
10 000 people split
you know whatever and then after it's
like you can get 125 bucks on like a
visa gift card or something
yeah and those corporations can [ __ ]
stall out in court for [ __ ] years and
years and years before you see a dime of
your money
it seems like you've been down this road
before so i've heard that
um all right the next one uh
this is from richard have you ever had
to wear your dad's dress clothes as a
kid because you got too fat
oh yeah that's an adult dude junior high
i would just like get ready in my dad i
would yeah
i'd go in i'd get like his russell
[ __ ] crew neck shirt
i had my jeans i'd get like a t or
something and [ __ ] you know i wore
all my dad's hoodies and sweatshirts oh
yeah and some of them didn't fit me
some of them were too small for me as a
fat you know [ __ ] eighth grader or
whatever
absolutely i wore i wore a sport coat of
my dad's
recently i can't remember what it was
for it was and
he's been wearing it for 30 years you
know he's a big guy but i'm
bigger at coins in the pocket
[Laughter]
he's a big guy but i'm bigger but
it's it's like a big guy's coat but when
you specifically wear a coat
for so long like 20 years he's had this
sport coat
it like molds to your body a little sure
so
like my my lumps and and shoulders and
everything is different
so i i felt like i was in the talking
heads it was just like weird like
it was big up here but didn't button
down here it was [ __ ] a nightmare
real trashy yeah it's yeah but in high
school i [ __ ] dude his jeans
his [ __ ] socks i couldn't wear my
dad's jeans socks i would i used to wear
my mom's socks too oh
socks in my house were a currency dude
they didn't
it might as well it was like bitcoin in
the 90s between my brother
my sister but they were just come and go
you know what i mean you can never
in the morning you're getting ready for
school and you don't have [ __ ] a pair
of freshies no i'd go right into my
mom's [ __ ] dresser and take a pair of
ankle socks 100
dude i was i was like doilies on them
and [ __ ] i have to like tuck them down
in the shoe
they're hot now yeah we were [ __ ]
trend centers i remember wearing my
mom's [ __ ] ankle socks with the
little tassel on the back
rip that thing off and [ __ ] keep it
this is
ankles looking like prince
uh this is another thing uh this is but
i was gonna ask you because i did it
yesterday if you're out of socks you
just take your girls right
yeah she's yeah yeah yeah yeah but she's
got all
goofy ones she's like we share
some like ankle socks or whatever you
know what i mean
like she can wear mine i can't wear hers
so if that makes sense
of course it does yeah so it's like some
of them are like all wacky and what the
[ __ ] is you know you get a pair of black
socks i'm a [ __ ] gentleman i got a
successful podcast i got a reptile keep
can't be caught wearing [ __ ] socks
that say tuesday on them or whatever
[ __ ] friday you know what i mean um
but this was the ultimate sign of trash
these kids these days don't know how
good they got it
ankle socks were pretty hard to come by
back in the day
very hard right that was like that
wasn't an
added expense it was like you had your
[ __ ] sock right and we were in the
middle too which was weird
because i missed and i know you missed
the hot one it was cool to wear [ __ ]
like
high stripes yeah i missed that yeah i
missed that too
so we were stuck in this dad like these
90s
no man's land with socks yeah they were
like they went halfway up and they
sucked
and you couldn't like push them down if
you had shorts on sure
so hold on this is what i want to get to
what if did you ever
turn a pair of socks into ankle socks
you could do
no cause i think i tried once no not
what i mean what i would do
cut them no i would either yeah so i'd
either fold it
i'd only pull it up to my ankle right
like pull it up to here
and then fold it under and put my shoe
on like that what the [ __ ]
t-bone oh yeah yeah weird
how did that that had to feel weird in
the front of your foot yeah not really
just you got used to it or whatever but
now you got you got a fresh pair of
ankle socks on when all these other
bozos are rolling around with the
[ __ ] squishy socks no i couldn't do
that or
you would pull it all the way up
depending on the sock and roll it back
down
over like do you see what i'm saying no
so i could see folding it back down yeah
you folded it either way this is [ __ ]
trash
sure you fold it back down under the
heel and it's so tight around and you
just pull your sock
you put it on and you've got a [ __ ]
hot pair of ankle socks no i'm telling
dude 98 when ankle socks were
it's the summer you got you got your
mom's doily socks on you got to do
something
can't be walking out wearing camo cargo
shorts with [ __ ] doily you could walk
over to dicks and buy a pack they were
like eight bucks
i got that kind of cash up until like a
week ago i didn't have that kind of cash
well what i was gonna say there was
nothing more especially a fat kid
who didn't have well-defined legs or
calves or ankles
or upper body or torso or neck or chin
sure sure
sure but the hair was popping that was
about it ah let's see how far that's
gone
uh a fat kid wearing
high socks scrunch high socks and shorts
is a bad look on a fat kid
most stuff is a real kind of fact but
also fat kids
can get away with stuff because they're
going ah he's fat he's goofy right you
know what i mean it's like
he's whatever you know i wasn't louis
anderson i know i'm just saying take
like uh
you know take a starve stavros for
example he
he just accepts this is what i am and he
can bigger guys can get by with stuff
a little bit better you know what i mean
he looks pretty sexy i'm not saying he
doesn't but
you got to own that like hey cause i
used to have a buddy this fat kid
and he had these he always wore like
these flashy shirts like neon green and
[ __ ] i'm like i would never be caught
dead on them but i'm like oh you own it
and you
you run with it and that's your fight
but that's when you have the equipment
to pull it off when you had the [ __ ]
those socks in the in the late 90s
[ __ ] sucked and it was a tough look
yeah it was bad it was a tough look i
will say this and it's going to lead us
to another line of questioning here
i have google searched wholesale socks
because stock prices are outrageous have
you ever
purchased that yeah right stock prices
are outrageous dude it's like it's like
16 bucks for three it's out
it's crazy out here that's not true
where are you buying socks well
amazon.com now wholesale oh my god
but have you guys ever bought and they
got finger holes anything wholesale
like bj's or sam's club i pay retail for
bjs
go ahead and i'm a friend of sam's
um i don't think i've ever bought
anything wholesale
we would do the cartons of cigs was the
thing we would get the
discount no don't even look at me no no
i had windows in my room
parents that loved me wholesale yeah no
wholesale i'm trying to think we would
get me like pipe
yeah we would get meat we had a meat guy
who got it was a whole
he was a meat whole salesman and we
would get it like off the [ __ ] back
of the truck
sure i mean that's awesome maybe i'm not
such an [ __ ] after all
it's not [ __ ] a crate of socks yeah
on amazon
and i mean you know exactly and we're
getting it from a friend you're buying
wholesale socks and you you're making
some cash too
how many coming up how many come in a
bundle i may have exaggerated it
forklifts out front hey we're out is
toby mcmuffin here we're out front
what does a pelt of cheap socks go for
yeah gorgeous socks
a cord that's what wood comes that's
what firewood comes
in uh
storage space it's at
my toby.com the one this is to show us
just like how new money trash our family
is
my brother rented a place in uh center
city the one time
and it was like him and like two of his
buddies like nice like queens village
like one of those like brown stones but
it was like just for the weekend or they
lived no like he lived there oh okay and
it had a fireplace in it right it was
like a three bedroom like one of those
like split level
type condo type thing and i had a
[ __ ] place he ordered a quart of wood
or something
they had two parking spots out like in
their courtyard
and the guy who just dumped the wood in
there so they would
it'd be like august and they had to burn
all this they had fires
going constantly and they lost two
parking spots
that's [ __ ] awesome i remember the
first time i heard somebody say the word
cord
quarter wood this guy's garbage yeah
where the [ __ ] that is yeah that
and like when you're driving around it
says like free clean dirt you're like
what are you doing
you see signs for free dirt hey clean
dirt wanted you're like what
we have we have a community mulch pile
in my hometown oh my god you
over by the turnpike of course it's over
by the dirt bike
i mean where else you're gonna put the
community mulch pile and the other time
i ever see people in there
taking stuff it's at night and they're
[ __ ] they're in like a little truck
not a full-size truck
they're in a ranger yeah that's like one
guy
shoveling like what the [ __ ] are you
doing that's what guys shove a little
one guy picking ticks out of his leg
this guy had to get out of the house
he's like headlights on it
that's a tough look a community mulch
pile
yikes a lot of problems are buried over
by that mulch box
oh yeah oh god that's so funny
yeah it's trashy we even we have that
and you know we have an abundance of in
our area which
admit leads me to believe we're garbage
we have multiple quarries in my neighbor
in my area yeah it's not a good
we at least have two and two's too many
yeah there's one in montgomeryville and
there's and there's one
uh over by east norton i don't like it
i don't know what they're digging for
yeah that's too much so godzilla versus
kong started
that's fine um well i told you we went i
mean we've talked about i think on
carly's
carly's first episode i went to it my
mom took us to a sock factory
right we were like going back to school
shop and we pulled up to a sock factory
i was like lady i am not going in here
yeah it was a tough luck i always hated
the way like burlington coat factory
smelled we never did that that was like
regardless of how poor we were like
you're at a sock factory i know like
regardless of how tight money was at
times that was like my
but the shame because they grew up so
poor that like they got to a certain
level and it's like we're not doing that
like she would like
i'll go into debt at old navy
before we go to burlington code factor
triple factor which was which we have
been
we we've had a credit card declined at
old navy one time oh
really yeah it was tough fantastic um
all right this is from pond is it trash
to run the heater in your car to keep it
from overheating
that's yeah you need mechanic work yeah
both i had two chevy luminaires my
brother had never even heard of that to
be honest oh really
no yeah so i know if that if it's in the
summer and you're in traffic
we've had to turn the air conditioner
off because it'll run hot overheat
yeah so what happens is i don't know if
it's older cars or newer cars whatever i
might i had two 95 chevy luminaires my
brother had one and i had one
silver silver and white and both of them
isn't hers so i don't i
they would overheat i guess there was
like a leak of antifreeze or whatever
both of them at the same time i don't
know i forget weird
yeah i don't know i think they might
have been separate times two lemons
[Laughter]
so i remember drunk
and i remember i do we were this is when
we were like gambling a lot is like high
schoolers and we drove down to atlantic
city and no one had a car but me and i
had
i had my car and i'm like it's overheats
like i only
use it to zip around you got to turn the
heat on sometimes
it's all right on the highway because
the wind the intake's coming in so quick
to cool the engine down
but dude i remember i frisbee up there i
didn't tell my buddies and they were
like friends that i wasn't really that
close with you know what i mean it
wasn't like you know
two of like my guys like that i'm still
a friend they were like more
acquaintances
okay and i'm driving down and we're
driving back gambling associates
sure and i got to keep people that would
want to go to atlantic city when you're
17 at 2 o'clock in the morning yeah on a
tuesday yeah so we're driving back up to
philly and i got
i have to ha it's like you know it's
probably like may
right so it's like a may night it's like
nice like windows down and i got the
heat
[ __ ] cranking and the one i didn't
tell the one kid's like dude can we turn
the heat off
i'm like nah man we can't because we're
not gonna make it home
it was like a system you had to keep the
heat up the windows down a little bit
and then like you could turn it off if
you were moving fast enough
it would cool it down itself naturally
i'm 17 i'm down 500 bucks and i'm
sweating my balls off jesus
dude it was tough so go to a party or
something like that
get a [ __ ] keg go to a movie or
something with you
jesus i mean we were doing that as well
[ __ ] driving
pc trying to make things right i just
had i just had bad
[ __ ] uh trying to get one big score
we were i keep the heat off in my car
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right this is uh trash
this is from johnny [ __ ]
i believe it's doctor johnny shipballs
shitball i'm not mistaken um
in a single in a single occup
the t-bone's got the gig t-bone's got
the chuckles
it's just i can't believe that this is
our career
we're having a good time
i got a new kia off doctor
all right in a single occupancy bathroom
situation where the bathroom is occupied
is it garbagio for a man to use the
woman's restroom or vice versa
i understand exactly what he's talking
about yeah it's not that complicated
it's not an sad question this one i get
uh i'm fine with that single occupancy
i'm totally fine you know who's not yeah
of course you are
all right well i mean i'm not going in
there if i go into the women's room
which i have
for sure i'm very courteous
of my stream you know what i mean i i
don't leave a mess
i'm in and out you know that type thing
i'm i it's fine i think
you think but you know who doesn't think
who the females that are using
that bathroom i always catch looks and
i'll tell you what little [ __ ]
well like when they're waiting there and
you open the door you're not the person
they want to see
just optically you're not the guy you
want to see i'm a good looking in shape
hot guys
[Laughter]
are you [ __ ] david hasselhoff they
want to come in with me you know what i
mean
i was just finishing wiping you want to
commit
i never [ __ ] in public like that either
i mean if i'm doing that i'm peeing for
the most part
oh unless i'm real hemmed up i will
specifically
go into the in into single occupancy
go to the women's to make a do-do well
that's why you're getting a look that's
usually the cleanest and the nicest
yeah that's why you're getting looks it
sounds like you're [ __ ] strangling
chickens in there
have you ever been walked in on mid-dump
by a member of the opposite sex where
at like in one of these bathrooms or
like in like a at home
uh no it's strange i never have no never
never
please tell us where would this occur it
happened to me i was in high school and
there was a
oh that's a tough look dude pooping in
high school you might as well [ __ ]
change schools
dude but here's the thing who pooped in
ice i'd [ __ ] my pants before i [ __ ]
pooped in high school it was during a
rehearsal for a play
i was i was just getting sadder inside
this mid costume change
so i was completely naked and this chick
but like
i don't know she had the most out of
piss so like she bust in like the
[ __ ] swat team
on old 16 year old t-bone with a whole
nude drop of the dude
big uncut hog on him i've i don't think
i've ever laughed harder she looks so
horrified at his instantly burst
that level was it a single occupancy
bathroom sure was so it was non-gender
correct it was just the bathroom correct
and you didn't lock the door i
thought i did yeah that happened uh to
maybe that's how you get your kicks
previous yes no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no
that happened at previous guest reggie
conquest at stand-up new york he would
just we had he just we just moved up he
just started doing check spots at
stand-up new york
and he went to before a spot he went
down to take a [ __ ] and he
this is when we found out he takes his
shirt off every time when he takes a
[ __ ] in public or not
so he's downstairs [ __ ] dude shirtless
dump is so funny to me
in public at work at a comedy club at
like 9 00 p.m
and he's [ __ ] and a woman
walks in and she's like oh i'm sorry
closes the door then he goes right up on
stage and she's sitting in the front row
and he's like yo i got to tell everybody
this lady just walked in on me [ __ ]
with my shirt with my shirt off yeah
that's trashy
that's good i don't think there's
anything wrong with it no i mean you
know if it
unless your women's room is always so
much nicer
it's yeah so much nicer
except the comedy clubs i think it
doesn't matter people are lawless
yeah that's like nightclub-ish people
are when there's booze involved it's you
[ __ ] no man's land but a nice
restaurant everything's yankee stadium
yeah
my nose is running oh great got
allergies um
all right this next one uh this is from
robert mcrae
uh have you ever used at a store or
restaurant or anything
uh the punch card and got enough to get
something for free or half off never
made it i mean i
i [ __ ] the yogurt place downstairs we
go [ __ ] all the time
and we have 1900 punch cards from them
because we never ever take it no i gotta
say last week
yeah my haircut your haircut which
raises the next question
so i go to this place on 57th street and
i've been going there for
probably two two years now and uh
they've it's i've never even i've never
been the guy to
t it's just lived in my wallet and they
ask every time and i go oh [ __ ] yeah i
do like i always forget and they go oh
do you have a punch card i go oh [ __ ] i
think i do and i always have it which is
crazy
that it's lasted with me it was all
tattered and ripped um because i need so
many co i have like the little wallet
so i need so many cards now it's
stretched out so i need so many cards in
there so they don't fall out if that
makes sense
you know what i mean no it makes perfect
yeah so it's like i have like i have
like an
empty td bank gift card in here just to
keep it full
so that's why oh that's why they keep
the piece that's why the that's why it
always lasted
because i needed it in there you know so
this
i didn't even realize how many i had or
anything and he goes oh i got my hair
cut last week he goes oh you have a
punch card
and i go yeah and he goes oh this is
your free one and i felt like such a
[ __ ] dork
like such a goober and he's like this is
your free one
and now i go does he not get paid on
like i don't know how that works
he didn't seem excited let's put it that
way you give him
i hope you gave him whatever you were
gonna give him for the haircut and
walked away
i gave him 20 cash that went right to
his pocket that's great that's good
right
i mean the haircut's 30 plus a tip wait
a minute well
haircuts 30 yeah oh so we call i so
my hair cuts 40 bucks with tip i do 30
procedures i do 30 and 10. yeah they got
to get the hubble telescope involved to
get these
[ __ ] plants some seedlings on me um
but i didn't i didn't know what to do
because he wasn't like oh cool like you
should have gave
you should have gave him the 40.
but see this is where it gets hairy
because they don't accept
cat they don't accept i was going to pay
on carter then you can't tip on the card
they only take cash and tips okay
and i only had 20 and 10 on me because i
wasn't exp i was expecting to put the
haircut on the card
and then give him ten okay so i don't
have
the resources to give him the 40. let's
hit him with the 20. let's take a step
back
sure if you're going to a place to get
your hair cut and they
and punch cards are involved sure you're
garbage yeah
that's that's strictly for yogurt
certain coffee places it's a nice place
and maybe a sandwich
i gotta tell you el oh i'm not i'm not
saying it's not trashy that's for
sure trashy i am garbage for even
and keeping the card and using it to
completion
uh but it's a no i i can't gotham barber
is on 57
it's a [ __ ] nice shot i'll ask you if
you got that haircut for free
[Laughter]
um but yeah that would just as the first
time i felt
i dude i like went home i had a shower
not even for the hair just to like
get the [ __ ] and get the garbage off of
me it was a tough look
yeah i've mentioned this before the only
thing similar to that that the foleys
have used
over the years uh is our palermos pizza
slices
which palermos gives you a little pizza
slice magnets
and then when you get enough to make a
whole pie oh you
bring it right hold on you break them in
and get a piece i forgot about this holy
[ __ ]
last so easter sunday or whatever easter
we go down the shore we go down the
shore every i think i might have been
saving this for hard feelings or
whatever i don't know
but i i completely forgot we go down
we're down the shore right mm-hmm
and uh we're getting pizzas
did i tell you that did we talk about
this no pop-pop just said something to
do with palermos no but it has to do
with the pizza so we go to sam's we're
saying down the shore there's sam's and
max we're a sam's household
through and through we have been for
[ __ ] 30 years we're sam's house
so my brother-in-law collects
the cuts them off the front of the box
like the coupon like a lot of pizza
places do that
and we had hundreds of them like we
could go get like 50 pies that we've
just been collecting over the years
so i'm like i'll run up and get the
pizzas like i'll go like i'll drive to
get the pizzas or when i'll run up or
whatever and he goes okay so he goes
he comes back with like [ __ ] 70
of these cardboard cutouts 70. like he's
got like a [ __ ] ziploc like a big
ziplock music here we can use these i go
dude i don't
i i'm making a little bit of cash now
but even if i was dead broke
i would not i'm not paying with
cardboard that ain't [ __ ] happening
that ain't happening i don't care yeah
i'm like i can't be
on [ __ ] wildwood's boardwalk [ __ ]
shelling what's that two how many you
got there three
four cheese and [ __ ] sauce all over
my hands no [ __ ]
dude i was like that's embarrassing but
then wait
is it one for one pizza no it's ten
so every how many pizzas were you
getting six or something so you were
rolling in there with like six
well so that this raises so then my
brother-in-law goes let's do
two let's just do two pies with the
coupons
i'm sure they have some type of
regulation well then my cousin goes well
let's just get the embarrassment over
with and just spend all these now so
we're not like we don't
like let's just get up get rid of them
and do it oh that's great if he wants to
go well that's what i said hey
i'm like dude i'll drive you yeah i'm
like i'm staying in a car i'm like
that's when i tapped out i'm like i'm
[ __ ] i'm the car guy
i'm the wheel man i ain't going up there
yeah with [ __ ] cardboard it ain't
happening
no embarrassing baby's got shades on an
advisor
sitting low so i got a fake mustache
there's just a pile of sigs next to the
window
can tell i've been waiting for an hour
i'm all nervous
it also says i get a free hoagie if i uh
turn this upside down and a bucket of
fries
yeah that's a tough look that's a tough
look
the whole thing i'm just the the punch
card
is trash mm-hmm it doesn't matter
i think you should think about a new
place to get a haircut
no the place is nice i think your cousin
they do it together and buy his own
pizza
it's my brother-in-law shout out to matt
um damn they make a nice pie down there
on the boards oh man sam's pizza you
never had it
never had sam's it was a mac and menko's
kid or whatever it's called this will
put mac and minko's
shane wildwood trash statement i'm
telling you
dude there's been there's like beauty
seems dude there's been like [ __ ]
family
you know feuds over people are trying to
bring max into the house it's like get
that the [ __ ] out of here
this is a sam's crib group of
intelligentsi over there huh
[Laughter]
all right let's do one or two more here
let's let's let's uh
there's some that i'm not you know this
is from thomas g are you worried about
any relatives knowing your social
security number i'm not sure
what the [ __ ] i'm not sure i really get
that one
my oh my my mom and dad know it at least
they don't know it
they have ax your mom knows your social
security number oh yeah
really oh my mom doesn't even know my
phone number
she she could assume my identity
tomorrow have me killed really
especially with their deep voice he
wouldn't even be able to tell it wasn't
me on the phone
damn um i thought i was gonna get a
laugh uh
sorry i was reading this is uh from
snake with arms
uh do you use your fingers to help get
the last bits of food onto your fork
come on which yeah for sure that's of
course i didn't realize you weren't
supposed to do that until i was like 15.
a little funny and my sister's like did
you just put your rice on your fork was
rice-a-roni
she's like did you just put use your
fingers to get the rice on there i go
yeah and my step-dad's like yeah that's
what you do and i'm like
now looking back i'm like that's not the
same first of all that's not the side
you want to be on
yeah fruit but first of all honey why
don't you pipe down you're sitting at
the same table
eating the same box of rice-a-roni yeah
try to flex on me yeah yeah yeah cause
you got a butter knife
we are who we are okay i didn't learn
until
my wife that the knife you were supposed
to do it with the knife
yeah yeah i was dude i'm just i'm still
a fingers guy you never see people eat
it with the fork upside down very good
my wife did that yeah they're very she's
very proper with the silver i feel like
before your wife you just use a fork
in your fist yeah dude i'm i'm an animal
i cut with my fork i use it like this i
don't use a knife when i cut i cut
everything with my fork
like the chicken that's a good sign why
that the meat's tender
uh yeah but it's just that i'm trash as
well dude i
ate a whole [ __ ] turkey dinner with
no knife
do you do you cut on the inside of the
fork
are you like a stab cut i have to pull
it out and then re-stab with the fork
wait say that again what i i know what
you're trying to say i just have to get
i
i have to understand it i know what
you're asking like through the tongs no
no that's
just like you're shooting nine ball
i go through the tongue sometimes maybe
you do
also what i do is i
maybe sometimes i got a feeling fat man
i think i lose
i think i used to i think i used to do
that as a kid when i first
started learning how to cut uh when i
was allowed to cut my own pancakes
slices hold on i know what i know
what you're trying to sorry explain it
more because i know i just can't get
there mentally i know what you're
talking about a steak
yeah you put your knife you put your
fork into the steak get a grip
and then you're going to cut your piece
are you cutting closer to you so you
have to then remove the fork
and re-grab the piece you just cut or do
you cut with a
knife away from the fork so that the
piece that you're cutting
just falls comes away with it oh comes
with the so the piece is on the fork
correct yeah do you need this do you
need to re you need to do two four kinks
for one bite
because that is [ __ ] tricky well
this is i understand what you're saying
i get it now
yeah and i don't think i've ever thought
of that where the meat would just that's
what you're supposed to do
oh really yeah like you but you would
have to you got to put your knife down
so you would have to maneuver
no what do you mean put your knife down
well the whole point is that you don't
have to put anything down
and then it's all good look you got a
fork i cut
fork i caught oh yeah yeah yeah that's
how you do so you have your knife and
your fork in your hand at all times
well this is what i do i i i put my fork
down after several bites to have
enjoy conversation with people also your
mom cuts up all your food for you yeah
you want to know what's really quiet
dinner time at the
i foley's you what except when that weed
whacker gets brought out
when when the shoveling starts just a
lot of heavy breathing
we lick it quiet those buttons work in
overtime
it sounds like the hull of a ship all
the buttons tightening
[Laughter]
you hear the whales
we've gone too deep but you can't take
it yep
rivets start shooting out
[Laughter]
um connery concerned things are sliding
along the day
um i do what's even trashier
this is bad this is really really bad i
cut everything i cut multiple pieces
right i'll cut like a half the chicken
breast
that's not bad hold on and then i eat i
switch over and the fork is in my right
hand
yeah that's okay i don't think so yeah
you could cut up half
have your little plate there but it's
because i can't go live after dipping
that's what i can't go left i can't eat
with my left hand
i can't do much with my left hand
so because the knife is in your right
hand right
yeah when you cut because you're
right-handed so then i have to cut
multiple pieces
put the knife down switch over and then
eat that's why i just that's why i call
you at restaurants i bet it's bad dude
if at any point you gotta swap
silverware
yeah switching hands yeah
that's like a game of three card monty
over here [ __ ] kill bills which is
switching swords uh all right let's wrap
it up
ah what a fun one gang uh we love you
kippy what do you got for him
guys uh thanks i mean the the uh the
support from everybody has been [ __ ]
fantastic whether you watch on youtube
you listen on itunes stitcher anything
the [ __ ] patreon support is
phenomenal
everybody in the facebook group we
[ __ ] love you it's it means the world
to us
uh if you're anywhere near raleigh or
nashville on 420 421 first leg of the
tour
grab a group of friends come on out hang
out we're going to be [ __ ] you know
drinking beers we're going to be
partying taking pics whatever you want
to do we're also
you guys are going to be able to ask us
questions we're going to ask your
questions it's going to be a good
[ __ ] time it's going to be like this
but we're all gonna be there together
yeah which is gonna be fun that's the
idea is we're trying to make it
the [ __ ] show we're trying to make it
the show so me and foley are gonna be on
stage together taking your questions
[ __ ] on you guys [ __ ] on your
brother your aunt you're wrong but if
somebody's doing a live pod where
the audience can't say anything we're
all gonna [ __ ] yeah that's we could
yeah that was another thing we don't
want to just do live podcasts where it's
just whatever we wanted to make it more
special and unique for each
person you know what i mean like for
each audience gets something special and
unique and you guys
get to ask us because we love hearing
from you guys we love riffing the
questions are [ __ ] fantastic
just based on how fun the the lot the
live stream that we do is
oh how fun it's gonna be when we're all
when we're [ __ ] on each other and
we're and we're all [ __ ] it's great
yeah i love it i can't be fun so come
out that's that's the pitch yeah we want
you to come out and experience this with
us it's going to be a good time
first leg [ __ ] rally in nashville
yeah we're moving on pretty much around
the country around the corner
you got like 9 yeah more than that more
than that so
fantastic yeah guys uh we'll see you out
there thank you so much we appreciate it
i'm at cameron comedy on all social
media
at age foley on ice on twitter
foldygrams on instagram
uh throw us a rate and review give us a
share all that good stuff we love you
guys